i'm at the brea improv right now in
california come see the babes um we got
i'm in san francisco uh september 8th to
the 10th at the uh cobbs comedy club
that's going to be fun fun then we got
madison wisconsin milwaukee wisconsin
chicago and minneapolis all at
chrisdcomedy.com and who knows the uk
might be on sale soon christy comedy.com
all right guys here's here's what we're
doing we're not going on the road again
until october but we got tons of cities
and you have tons of time to get good
tickets right now uh october 14th we're
in hamilton ontario okay uh toronto on
october 15th toronto you've been asking
me i'm there then we're going to
richmond virginia and we're going to
hershey pennsylvania we're going to
knoxville we're going to atlanta georgia
we're going to the alabama theater in
birmingham alabama we're going to
louisville kentucky we're going to
evansville indiana we are going to
florida by way of jacksonville tampa and
orlando and then of course in california
we have dates at sacramento santa rosa
and san jose everything is on sale right
now at
savilecanocomedy.com
you got a couple of months get some
friends together get some tickets come
have a good time
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate
but the feeling ain't the same and they
say they're hurt
you've genuinely never heard this i
swear to god i swear to god
the cameras are on right
i don't even know i feel like that's
just how we start the show
yeah i mean pick up the microphone
because literally
literally but you've never heard the
song
burned by usher it never heard it i'm
being honest it's one of those things
where i almost think like were you
abducted by aliens
from the summers of 19 of 2002
i feel how weird it must be because if
you know it when did ushers burn come
out pimp let's
do you know who usher is yes usher
raymond
i do know him
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
where the [ __ ] were you march 21st 2004
well i can look it up i do have my
journal literally
i want to know if you go back into your
diary right now it better say from 2004
to 2007 you were in a straight up coma i
i might have been in a straight up c
yeah burn was pushed back after
favorable responses to the song yeah now
i know that one that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah i knew there was a little jump
yeah okay
yeah right
now
literally down up and it doesn't tell me
it's it's just from my mommy screaming
yeah right right yeah yeah it's almost
like you like with like you not like an
american
man growing up like i've never heard the
song burned by usher it's like it's
almost like you're not from this planet
guys if you're watching right now in the
comments we know that you are and we
know that you are in the comments but
shout out er usher ursher first shout
out to raymond urscher raymond urscher a
lot of people say who a lot of people
say is the like our version our
uh uh errors michael j jackson i heard
that that's when he first came out he
was doing a lot of that popping and
locking awards and that's working and
you know what usher did you know that
you know the the the race to bieber
between usher and justin timberlake and
usher won that race usher owned bieber
right yes
like his um
his like he was like his uh mentor right
you know what
he owns him like his label ushers label
whatever i forgot what usher is oh so he
doesn't is that why he doesn't want to
do anything anymore
money
uh well you know yeah usher was getting
that bieber money oh boy if you're going
to get any type of money you want that b
you want that scooter got that beaver
money oh you want that bieber money do
you know i remember in the press
uh ursher uh
uh [ __ ] on justin timberlake yeah when
tim when timbo went solo
and he was doing he was doing his thing
he was really carving out a niche and
then ursula they were comparing him and
he goes you don't ever stop comparing me
to him we're not even in the same league
he's trash and then he had to walk those
he had to walk that back
he had to walk it he all the way he said
i was wrong about him he's ready for
this because you can you can't you can't
front on jay timbo fmk right now fmk
right now yeah
fmk yeah literally i'll i'll blow your
head off you don't answer this i
understand fmka ursher yeah justin
timberlake yeah michael jackson
uh i marry michael got it well no what
am i saying i was gonna say i marry
michael because he has money no crime
smile because he has money oh yeah but
i'm thinking everybody he has bb's money
so it doesn't matter so who is it it's
ursh er sure justin timberlake michael
jackson fmk hmm
i would it be crazy to k would i be
would people hate me if i could kill
somebody if i killed michael jackson a
percentage of the population is going to
hate you but the percentage population
hates you for not knowing burn by usher
okay
so i would say i would marry michael
jackson because
i'd like to live in his accommodation
and neverland yeah that's fine okay so
you marry mike who do you have this is a
non-criminalized criminal
this is this is just based off the
musician the music
and then i i guess i would
there's really no one i want to kill but
like
i think that i have to though or i'll
kill you okay i think i i think i know
more
justin timberlake songs
so i would probably have sex with him
which there's no connection there i
don't understand why that means that i
would have sex with him
it's a toss-up and i guess i would kill
usher because i haven't heard from him
in a while yeah you have everyone you
don't even know his music i don't know
his music so what good is he to me
interesting
see i like that i'd say i'd say for me
on that i'd actually
believe it or not
i'd i'd kill
i'd kill um would you come like a
jackson i'd kill justin timberlake okay
i'd kill justin timberlake why
because i'm not racist okay
um again and then i'd f
michael jackson just because why because
i think michael jackson if you look at
the way his hips move
and the daintiness of it that's what i
like in a woman is a body if you're a
woman you have a body like michael
jackson i mean michael jackson also
looks the most latina when like became a
white woman so i liked
that when michael jackson went white she
looked he looked like like a puerto
rican you are true and he it also he
also might be fun would you say you
would have sex with him or marry him i
have sex with him he it also might be
when i have sex with him because he
might make all the fun sounds yeah
yeah
like yeah and then and that would really
boost your confidence if you knew if he
was making all his signature sounds you
were doing a good job i would love it
yeah and then you'd have that little
glove on it'd be great yeah and then i'd
marry usher to get that bieber money in
the divorce and you ought to get to be
money yeah i'd marry i should no prenup
because i want that bieber money
wow what can what how is bieber's face
by the way is he ever gonna oh yeah
let's hope let's hope it's coming it's
because i uh
my uncle bought his niece for her sweet
16 six instead of having a sweet 16
bought him madison square garden biebs
tickets but then beeps cancel but he
can't get his money back because that's
not how they do it they're like we hold
your money pretty much like an escrow
until he comes back
so i'm trying to get her now just to
come in because my uncle's like listen i
you know i kind of spent my money on on
these tickets for her like you know
instead of sweet 16 i don't have the
money for another show and i can't get
my money back from bieber so i want to
try to get my uncle and my cousin harry
styles tickets do you know harry styles
uh i do know who he is i do not know him
specifically but he's probably a zaddy
he oh my god harry styles he's a daddy
harry styles walks around in a skirt all
day every day
straight that's i like harry styles a
new song as it was i don't listen to the
radio
it's good i don't know it's the radio at
all no well that's why you didn't never
heard burn that's probably why no gen
how long how long have i i'm not joking
around i swear to you i've never heard
that song before in my life burn never
heard it not neither did i hear that one
you just sang but so do you only hear
music if it's in on a movie like like
how do you consume music no i consume
music uh peripherally like i'm in a
store and music is playing and i hear
something i like a lot of times on
television soundtracks or like um
like uh
harry styles
dressed up like dorothy from wizard of
oz god but dead serious not [ __ ]
around
just out there this
which is fine i got no ish with that i
mean he's confident enough to do it he's
in a good one look at that suit that
looks like a couch you know if i could
dress like if you could dress like that
and pull it off you see his frame right
he's got a he's he's almost like a young
mick jagger well that's what they
compare him to this no i swear to god
ever he gets compared to you
a journalist for music that's what it is
i would dr i might dr i might be that
bold he almost is his body frame is like
a it's like a hanger like you just hang
he's like you just hang clothes on yeah
remember when we were younger you could
get like that thing where like it's a
cut out of a person maybe it was like i
don't know someone famous or maybe not
and then you could
like
attach clothes to him yeah and then i
know what you mean you bend the you bend
it back yeah and so it stays on you
change the pants
or sometimes they have a fridge magnets
i would like to get a harry styles on my
fridge with all different outfits that i
could put on him and i could change him
every day according to my mood right i
like that does that exist
i bet you that might exist
like you don't know what that is what's
that called it's a magnet when we're
kids did he get the subway tattoo he has
a sternum tattoo remember if you know
someone who's on hard times
buy them a 12-inch subway sandwich
tattoo on their back it's free subway
sandwiches for life it's fifty thousand
dollars fifty thousand dollars in gift
cards what does that mean they
calculated that at what one sandwich a
day
for the lifespan of an average human how
do they calculate that yeah i mean well
like what i would say the i would say
the average i would say the average
s let's say subway sandwich cost let's
just make it even let's say 10 you want
to say it's 10 bucks sure so 50 000.
so they're thinking on average you need
5 000 sandwiches roughly
i did i did wait why did i do this
i said we said 50 000 let's call the
sandwich because it is a foot long
this that's five thousand sandwiches
okay is what fifty thousand dollars of
gift cards so that does they have two
thousand dollars at least mean one a day
by the way we never talked about that
sandwiches a day
a day
until when 5 000 divided by 365 is 13.
in a year that's for life though oh in a
year how many 365 days in a year yeah
but that was 4 300. so let's see you
live so let's say you let's say you
lived
another 30 years
oh
times 30.
no this doesn't make any you wouldn't no
you'd only have enough sandwiches
you'd only have enough sandwiches for
like another 50. this is what i'm saying
that doesn't make sense they're calling
it for life but really what they're
saying is fifty thousand dollars worth
of sandwiches and honestly because of
this
by the way this is why i prefer quiznos
yeah
and by the way in gift cards
how funny that is like it's either like
a 50 000 gift card
i would give it to a family member for
christmas and be like i don't want this
yeah yeah fiberglass in the bread we
didn't talk about that so what happens
now
they just have fiberglass in the bread
do you know that i once did a subway
campaign or something like that and they
gave me a subway black card and it was
good for free sandwiches whenever so i
had that already you have the tattoo
card i it was like good for like a year
and then like you have to talk to them
and see if they'll like re-up it how
many sandwiches did you get that year no
joke it was unlimited no but how many
did you personally get i used it i use
it i didn't go i didn't have any more
well i might have more than i would have
in a year now would you pull it out for
the works like oh should he got the
black card or you would just swipe it
like any credit card it would just come
out to pay and i remember i would hand
it over because some people were like
what is this and i was like you don't
know about your own card
yeah but they gave me a black black card
and they said this is good at any subway
for any sandwich for for indefinitely do
you still have that i probably have the
car but i think i think at one point it
expired
uh subway let's see why they use the
same chemicals that they make yoga mats
for their bread so if you want if you if
you're looking to get a little yoga just
go go to subway and get a foot long wow
can i hear a grievance yeah
i
i was
scrolling instagram
and i came across an ad for a place that
i've gone to it's a boat it's called
bodega
it's a streetwear store and sneaker
store boston out of boston yeah right
and um i've i've patronized them
and uh i
saw some things i went to their website
and i bought a couple things and i got
mailed here and one of the things i
bought was a hat
and i got the hat and it was like a 50
hat and i tried it on and there is no
way a human being can wear this hat okay
i haven't i have it i'm going to show it
to you you mean to tell i said okay i'm
going to initiate a return
i went on to instagram i initiated a
return they gave me a ticket number and
everything and i tried to return it and
they never ever responded to me again
you tell me
okay you tell me
how is this supposed to be a hat that
somebody can wear
[Laughter]
[Music]
what head was this cut for that you're
selling this and then you're going radio
silent on the return request
whose head does this fit even if you're
saying this is the new style younger
kids are wearing it like this it's
supposed to be a shallow hat you wear it
to the back maybe okay fine who is
wearing this hat
okay
would you put it on where you like did
you try everything
oh god
i look down in the mirror and i go
there's no way for me to even do
anything like that
i swear to god
oh my god
it was
it was 45
plus tax and shipping and then i
initiated i went on i said i bought this
i want to return it they said look for
an email to bodega and it never came and
they they won't pick up the phone
nothing try that out
[Laughter]
you look like your special needs
i mean nothing no offense but you almost
look like you don't really care if it
fits or not but do you think that
you look like you're in the movie the
ringer
do you use ice cream
[Laughter]
wait wait wait do you think that you
just got a bad bad bad bad batch or this
is the style do you think
but just tell me the person that's
supposed to wear it tell me how i
genuinely this
i'm blaming bodega for not and their
instagram or instagram either you for
not getting back to me on the return but
the company present moment is the person
who sewed the hat on
yeah
it's like
it looks like a pull up union soldier
civil war hat he kind of looks like like
what they would wear in the civil war
when half their heads were blown off
from a cannonball
it's like that
it's like similar to that
yeah like look look like that's what you
look like right there i was so excited
to get the hat right because what i like
you look like
you could you know i got it and i was
like here we go and i looked at it i was
like all right and i went right in the
mirror and i went like this
i was like what is this how is this even
from the side it looks insane
it looks insane from this
and so when you and were you like kind
of sitting with him for a moment being
like is it my head is it the hat i was
looking in the mirror like
i was speechless
and then i turned to her and i was like
look at this and we just cried laughing
it was like the and the end of and the
stones to charge for 45
plus shipping and tax
it literally
is genuinely i'm prepared to say this is
the worst hat i've ever seen in my life
i know i don't think it would fit a
newborn like it looks like it could be
from like a key and peel sketch
[Laughter]
[Music]
what the best sketch show of all time
and you know i i would i would be like
um
well i guess you could put it up like is
that an l sketch show yeah but i think
as far as like not in front of a studio
audience although keyanp kind of was in
front of students i would say yes uh at
least for us but then i think you should
leave came out
and i was like
she's coming out with season three yeah
and i was like man like it's as good
yeah so what about chappelle what about
your posture i think he and peel is
better than chappelle i do that i
genuinely do yeah i mean i'm a huge dave
chappelle fans too i think he and peel
pound-for-pound i mean they changed the
game the king and pl gremlin sketch
is just it's like the i think the best
sketch ever i've ever seen in my life
when they're like throwing like the the
stuff yeah yeah the gremlin yeah he's
like jordan feels playing like that gay
no way i want to see nope have you seen
nope yet
no but i audibly i literally i was
seeing the movie um the viking the
northmen i've seen the northmen um with
jazz like a month ago and we saw the
coming attractions in the movie theater
four four um nope for for nope and it's
like the scary move or whatever and then
the name of the movie just it comes up
nope we audibly laughed out loud when i
was like what a hilarious day for the
movie but have you actually seen it no i
want to nope i haven't but i want to i
want to see it really bad i saw the
actor who left too it's kind of funny
when i'm like nope i saw the actor who's
in the lead of all those jordan peel
movies um the guy what's up oh yeah yeah
um uh yes daniel is his name daniel he's
uh english actually yeah i saw him in uh
he's amazing he walked past me in l.a
and i was and i was like oh what's up
man and then and then he was like hi
like like as if to be like
like like he like he like i was like
what's up like you know like just
because i've like noticed that he's like
a famous actor but like didn't know his
name or or anything he was like hey
and then just kind of looked at me and i
was like all right
like i'll see you later because we're at
the soho house you were like
and i just didn't have anything to say
to him right like you know what i mean
because i didn't know anything else
about him like yeah like and and and
then i was with my friend and my friends
like i thought that guy was dead and i'm
like that's chadwick boseman like oh
yeah [ __ ] dummy yeah and and and then
and you know chadwick boson played james
brown in a biopic in 2013. do you know
that chadwick boseman is one of the best
actors of our time do you know he's such
a was such a fantastic actor
you know how like good he was like just
from what i've heard and heard and read
i mean i've seen him in stuff yeah no he
was like legitimately like he did black
panther like dying of cancer yeah i know
which is like not wild
that's why i was just on a plane um
coming home and i saw a james brown
biopic i'm like when did this come out
it was 2013 and he played him yeah i was
like i wonder i wonder why i haven't
heard of that
i i don't i think um
i um uh uh wait what is it what do you
have up monk walks almost vertically
like these monks can just walk you know
monks do not jerk off
they do not jerk off not from the
footage i've seen
yeah
and they and they do not um they
meditate for like 19 hours a day
that is there
the guy's just pointing out the monks
can walk up with no ropes and he has to
like climb with ropes up the mountain
oh my god he's he's almost walking
straight up in the air they're like
goats
there must be some kind of technique
he's also barefoot
i mean that's straight up and he doesn't
look like he's out of breath he's also
doing it with no underwear on
in a bed sheet
what do what do monks do
what do i'm telling you monks they sit
and they meditate that's what they do
all day and they eat but but that's it
though
if i'm a kid in tibet and that is one of
my potential life paths
and one day i i'm like i might be a monk
and you're agreeing to do what then to
put on an outfit and just sit no i
genuinely think you're you're trying to
find out life's meaning look what do
monks do all day they do the things that
make them communal uh mass prayer
reflection service they also do things
that make them unique
exercise collecting composing and
cooking
sounds like some life i mean
i mean i'm going to exercise a little
bit i'm going to collect some some
whatever they collect what do they
collect
it actually sounds like what jasmine
does
this is this is just this is she's
cooking she's exercising she's composing
yeah she's reflecting
yeah she
what do monks they work out all day
monks are yeah that's so funny to see
amongst a monkey like in like a little
like mcgregor basketball shorts
that's ridiculous
but what are they like do they
no i think amongst monks monks amongst
monks do they let their
their head down like will a monk tell
another monk like an off-color joke i
think so i think so i think monks are
people and then when we show up every
day just like hum
yeah they're just hum they they i we
should go to tibet and i wonder if you
can go look at monks if you can just go
watch monks in tibet you just watch them
like this watch out because
because i think that they just sit and
meditate on the steps of temples all
over you know wherever you know but
they're already
exercising reflecting
they're making 65 grand a year not bad
they get paid
i thought they just like live for free
wait a second there's buddhist monks in
the united states and they're only
making eight they make on the low end 18
grand on the high end 65. you can't live
off that money
no no not guys america they have one
outfit and they don't need a barber
they don't need a barb yeah do you
that's another thing that do you have to
shave your head to be a monk why can't
monks have hair
why are monks not allowed to have hair
why do monks sleep so little
okay so the precepts of to be a monk is
you got to be committed you have to
commit to this to abstain from killing
living being so don't kill nothing
that's not even a bug stealing sexual
misconduct lying and intoxication
with the ninth precept buddhists refrain
from lying in a high or luxurious
sleeping place
they refrain from oh like like
physically they can't lie right so they
can't they can't lay down
in a luxurious place monks that take it
a step further aim to sleep upright to
reduce the need for sleep
that's not healthy at all but i bet you
they meditate so much they don't need to
sleep as much as you ever see the monk
do you ever see the monk
who lit himself on fire in protest of
the vietnam war of course famous and
then he literally like practiced a
meditative state where he felt no pain
that's he doesn't even flinch how do we
know that because he doesn't even flinch
didn't he die yeah but he just he he
said that he got himself to a state
where he is crazy look at this they eat
beans noodle soups and stir-fried or
steamed vegetable dishes they have the
same diet as homeless pimp
why is it not monk
that's a good question hey i'm a monk
yeah why oh why
m-u-n-k
yeah
what about monk fruit does that have
anything to do with monks
can anyone become a monk click that
to become a monk at downside you need to
be a be a confirmed and practicing
catholic a man over the age of 18 okay
in good mental and physical health
that's what we go to better help if
possible involved in the life of your
parish or something similar unmarried
and no dependents
you can't claim anyone there has to be a
monk out there who's who's getting it on
the side there has to be a horn it's
impossible if it's impossible not to
have that there has to be many many
monks humans had sex with women can a
woman be a monk or can it only be a god
or what is the what is the female
equivalent of a monk
yeah is it a nun i mean you know i mean
if you're a monk and you're watching and
we know that you are sound off in the
comments about your monk experience
please yeah is there a monk listening to
the pod right now are we helping you
meditate
none
monk is short for monastery they got
female monks
buddhists nuns and monks today follow
the vin vinyasa rules about hair
what if what are the vin
vinaya rules about hair why can't monks
have hair what's the deal with what's
the problem
with hair because if they if it's just
about they go bald we got keeps.com
that's
they haven't sponsored anymore they
haven't sponsored us in a minute forget
i said that yeah don't worry about that
okay
the rules made by the buddha for his
ordained followers are recorded in
attacks called the vineyard pitaka in
the pali vineyard pataka which sounds
like it's sound that sounds like a nice
[ __ ] health food bowl for bioball
in a section called the kandakaka the
rules say that hair should be shaved at
least every two months or when the hair
has grown to the length of two finger
widths so we do not
you got to cut your hair
yeah i mean okay
you have to shave your head completely
yeah i've seen you in basketball i've
seen that yeah i've shaved it i mean you
know you you just you you're free it's
easy for on the go it's very easy for
the girl
they're not going anywhere ridding
yourself of your hair serves as a symbol
of renunciation of worldly ego and
fashion
and that's also why muslim uh women wear
the hajibs why they cover their hair
because they're like showing like it
doesn't matter like yes i have beautiful
hair right now but only my husband's
gonna see that right
well let me ask you a question though
because isn't there like another version
of the monk where they have like a
ponytail that is like comes like down to
the floor where they grow the hair
forever yeah what yeah maybe that's when
that maybe they do that with like one of
their brothers is in prison
you ever heard that that's what people
do they grow on ponytails if one of
their brothers are in prison
see like what about that
um do you ever think two monks get into
a like a fist fight i do well they have
to renounce everything like that so
you ever think a situation arose where
they got irks with each other and they
just threw hands 100 i think there's no
way even if you are sitting there
meditating 19 20 hours a day there's no
way you can cohabitate with someone for
all those years and not at some point
they piss you off right i mean monks
have feelings yeah you think they got
covered
probably bugs
i wonder i mean it was everywhere
yeah i don't know but i don't know if it
hits a bet
look at this guy monk's got sneakers on
he's wearing sketches this month that's
one of these monks comes out with a hat
from bodega
shaolin temple wow look at that shaolin
yeah
oh wow these monks will beat the [ __ ]
out of you too oh my god
what is going on oh my god he's like a
spider monkey oh my god it's like real
life looks like this guys
oh my god the flexibility on these guys
is yeah
he's got left look he's got he's got a
monk in the trunk this guy
holy [ __ ] what is this isis so they also
so they also completely do synchronize
dancing china's largest martial arts
school they practice at the shaolin
monastery
that's got to be fun you got to feel
like you're part of something right
there could you imagine you're like you
invade china you can get your ass kicked
by a [ __ ] monk
how come these guys don't have a shaved
head
i guess they're monks in training they
haven't earned the right yet to shave
their head if if we took away all
weaponry of any kind okay any kind and
war still had to exist but it was just
on the ground of physical fighting
who do you think's winning that like
what country yeah
honestly i probably got to be israel
krav maga is a style of fighting that is
specifically designed it's not about
fair fights it is designed to disable
you they go for the eyes they go for the
genitals they'll stick a finger up your
butt krav maga they go to disable you
because they're like israel like our
enemies are surrounding us we don't have
time to [ __ ] be like oh this is a
discipline it's like no no i'm going to
teach you how to even more than
brazilian jiu-jitsu
i don't know more but i you know they'll
try to rip your throat out
but you think everything you think
everybody over the military all those
craft
in the israeli military also all knows
krav and everyone in israel has to do
two years in the military you go on the
weekends you know you could do weekends
in jail too did i ever tell you that did
we talk about that no you can do you can
who gives you that option it depends on
your crime you can
serve a part of your sentence on just in
on the weekends i think it's canada you
can go to jail on the weekends you can
literally serve a five-year sentence but
it's just weekends
so i can go through five years five
i said it before and i'll say it again
summer's in full swing and the
celebration begins during the summer of
dash pass by doordash
weekly member only offers and new items
released every week you can shine bright
and feel cool all season long babe
ordering your summer essentials with the
dash pass by doordash is a great way to
get everything you need during the
summer of dash pass you can save money
and access members only offers that will
help you feel easy and breezy and
beautiful cover girl and all season long
i love doordash because like the other
night i needed milk for my baby and i
just doored there because it's not just
restaurants it's not how about that it's
not and i'm telling you you can shine
bright during door dash your summer of
dash pass and you're going to get 50 off
your first order up to 15 value if you
just use the promo code hey babe at
check out when you spend 12 or more
that's 50
off your first order up to a 15 value
when you sign up for doordash during
summer of dash pass using promo code hey
babe don't forget that's code hey babe
for 50 off your first order up to 15
dollar value dash pass benefits only on
eligible orders that meet the minimum
subtotal terms apply butcher box butcher
box babe 100 percent aggressive
free range organic chicken wild caught
seafood and so much more uh you can it's
a subscription-based service that
delivers meat fresh they're it's frozen
fresh it's delivered to your house 14
pounds i get at a clip everything in
life now is subscription-based i want a
subscription to meet so do i butcher box
gives me a subscription to me and you
can pause it or cancel it anytime it's
not like you know what do you mean he
don't eat no meat what's that from
um my big fat uh greek wedding oh really
yeah i got to see that one again i guess
i remember it being good
uh look every month a butcher box ships
and cure
a curated selection shadow who tom hanks
it's his wi-fi is the one who found um
the ladies
yeah
nina vidal said soon she
found her because she was doing a
one-man show yes
it was tom hanks wife that's right got
it okay but back to butcher box guys
every month bookshelves
curated selection of high quality meat
right to your home free shipping in the
continentals of the u.s no antibiotics
in their meats no added hormones like i
said it's packed fresh and [ __ ] frozen
for convenience save time going to the
grocery store worrying about picking out
good meat
customize your own box or go with one of
theirs it's all 100 high quality meat
tom hanks loves it uh less than six
bucks per average on a meal so get
summer sizzling started with this
special butcher box deal for our
listeners free bacon for life uh of your
membership plus ten dollars all right
yeah i mean how do you not love this
company you get yourself a big fat greek
wedding on blu-ray you get your bacon in
the house and you chomp away in that
bacon and you watch nina vardalos that's
what it is sign up today
dot com slash hey babe and use code hey
babe to get one pack of free bacon in
every box for the life of your
membership plus ten dollars off your
first order that's butcherbox.com hey
babe and use the code hey babe to claim
this deal shout out nina vardalos
because if you if you really for five
years that's like to 1800 days that
means you have to go for weekends for
the rest of your life
no i think it's like you get a chance
like the judge would be like what do you
want to do do you want to do a year in
jail straight you want to do five years
but it's only on the weekends what would
you do
google weekends in jail oh here we go
yeah look defense attorneys prosecutors
can request this option yeah we instead
of a traditional imprisonment weekend
jail is given to people convicted of
non-violent crimes such as duis chronic
speeding
petty thefts and failure to pay child
support you can go to weekends so you
can go to jail come out and then go to
jail come out go to jail you literally
monday you're free
you're out
no but right but then you go back you
got to go back friday right
so that's i've never heard of that in my
entire life it's it's what look why
people get sentenced to weekend jail
yeah
uh part-time jail alternative to
probation if offenders have full-time
jobs during the week and spend their
weekends in jail they say this thing is
increasing throughout the country
wow
i i what would you do would you rather
just bang it out in a year get it over
would you do five years of weekends in
jail what would you do okay so you're
telling me five years of weekends five
years for five years every weekend every
52 weekends you are going to jail so
saturday sunday saturday sunday that's
104 days a year so over five to five
it's 520 or you could just go a year
straight everything so 520 days
cumulative over five years or 365
straight
oh
you can't go to weddings
yeah you can't you can't get into comedy
you can't watch you can't you know go to
football
okay because i'm kind of jailer
i don't know that's a tough one imagine
like hanging out with someone like and
then like they're like yo tomorrow we're
going to the game you want to come like
i can't
i [ __ ]
i kicked a lady in the vagina a couple
of years ago and uh my studies and
sundays are locked up for a few years
yeah i think i do five years of weekends
i don't want to be in jail for a year
neither do i but
well yeah it seems like one year in jail
will rob you of more life even though
the other one is more days the other one
is 40 almost 40 more though right like
oh no no maybe like it's actually 33
more days though think about it it's
like when you win the lotto and you want
to take over 20 years or you want to get
paid out i get paid out yeah
well that means that and for that logic
you do the year how is the hat starting
to look better now that i'm wearing it
and actually believe it or not it's
starting to look worse
[Laughter]
you look like you're in like uh like the
white sox in nineteen freaking oh yeah
yeah like i'm shoeless joe jackson yeah
uh okay i think that i might just be
like go for a year i'll tell you why
okay
i mentally prepare myself i i i'm like a
monk up in there right okay i'm
exercising i'm reading i'm bettering
myself
okay
and i'm making a plan for my future and
it's like
one year of only working on yourself
okay you get visitors here and there but
like you know i'd come out healthier
hopefully not raped
i would come out at reading a lot more
books
and maybe with a some clarity that i
didn't have before
a year can go i'm sure it's slow believe
me i think it's be terrible to be
nacelle but i don't know man something
about not having a weekend for five
years every single
week you gotta mentally prepare to go
back in there again
every single week that's what would
weigh on you
but then i started you could do i wanna
miss a year of my family's life or just
miss little cause in a way that's rough
just think about our life though in a
way we're gone almost every weekend
anyway
yeah so we our lives personally you and
i wouldn't change that much maybe we
just do stand up in the jail on weekends
yeah we go can i do my central i'm doing
i'll go to different jails
but i do shows there right and but i
don't get paid
you don't get paid right right yeah i
think you remember you know because you
don't know what you could do you could
just say every saturday and sunday i'm
going in there and i'm going to like
train
on set on the weekends like you dedicate
your weekends to to meditating
i don't know yeah what would you do pimp
a year a weekend's in jail
what do you think what do you think your
partner would want you to do weekends
for five years i'd go to your guys
schedule
i think my partner
dude five years ago my partner would
prefer five years of weekends yeah well
you could still have a functioning kind
of normal life if you can you can but
think about the guy me and you go in at
the same time you take five i take one
terrible for that year i'm losing touch
with people i'm kind of like it's a very
tough hit it's gonna it might change me
but when i get out in a year you're
going in for four more years
like you would have restart returned a
life of normalcy
way before i did sound off in the
comments what you would choose and why
tell us what was that last one with nick
cannon
um was nick
congratulations are in order for johnny
manziel's ex-wife bree tisi
because nick cannon got has just had a
baby with her yeah it was just wait a
minute but was he did they have an
affair with off mantel
are you saying manzel just divorced her
and then nick cannon got with him okay i
have a couple of questions
he has yet another child i have a couple
questions number one is he not married
to mariah carey nick hannon no they got
divorced years ago okay but they have a
great co-parenting relationship okay as
we talked about in the nick cannon show
oh really yeah okay number two doesn't
he have like 10 kids i think he might
have 10 children
and he said he'll continue to have
children he loves having kids he said he
will continue to do this all day but how
can he give enough time to those
children
with his work schedule like how could he
imagine having 10 kids and wanting to
make sure you have enough face time with
all of them
i think some of his kids are older now
maybe so i know he has twins with more
oh he has seven kids well eight well
eight now
we have powerful queen cannon moroccan
scott cannon zen what is children's
names we got zen cannon moroccan
oh my god zillionaire zillionaire
zillionaire cannon and then golden
golden cannon
zion cannon okay mix alone and then go
back the other way
mixolodian like nickelodeon monroe
monroe really lucked out there
yeah uh and steve golding
why is megan good trending did he used
to go with megan good probably
well
whatever happened to megan good well
she's probably still doing it who's
megan good megan good's a a a well-known
um actress you've seen her in a bunch of
stuff okay she's a good actress megan
good
um
yeah i don't um i don't know oh we want
to talk about this this woman who was
left in the neck brace after safari park
proposal goes wildly wrong this guy
tried to propose to his wife his fiancee
make it all nice and special and then a
giraffe came and [ __ ] knocked this
lady out uh i mean please tell me
there's the full video if they have the
freeze frame they they have to
we have the favorite video it looked
like it was a tickety hogany
right there a ticket that would talk to
them
i have zero desire to ever go on a
safari
yeah i don't want to do like a real one
you would go to you would go like to in
to a safari all right if i could be
flown in do the safari in florida i'm a
little weary of staying like in the
stuff in a safari like like sleeping in
the desert and stuff like that yeah like
like where there's just roaming
elephants and lions and stuff like that
but i i'm sure it's like an unbelievable
experience can you imagine seeing those
i don't know man seeing those things in
the wild
well my friend did it in i think like
bots oh here we go
what the hell's that name monastery is
one of nick cannon's kids no
oh
oh that wasn't as bad as that was she
yeah but she's got to be in the neck
brace though she probably got
that's just you know a giraffe could
straight up kill you in a split second
right yeah do you know that they just
swing their heads and they can knock
your head off yo 100 yeah yeah i mean
it's so that that those but it's so
powerful they don't want you i'm
surprised that she was even in a
position where the giraffe could come up
like that i when i go to the nashville
zoo if you ever want to go to the zoo
when you're in nashville let me know i
gotta hook up all i want to do when i go
to nashville back tour and they take us
to the giraffe like behind the scenes
and everything they don't even want
uh you have to be at a level where the
giraffe at full extension is kind of
just getting their head up to you like
that and you still aren't supposed to go
that close to them because if they just
rear back and swing they will they can
literally kill you do you have a
connection yes for disneyland to do like
the behind the scenes back door was
disney like impossible i think it might
be slightly impossible
uh
i i know someone who who's who's done it
so i can see if what they know
okay because i would love because i'm
gonna be over there with a family of six
yeah i i i think they don't like i think
it's expensive it's expensive and they
don't like cut like i i don't know if
like they're like tom hanks pays for it
but like i think that because my friend
just went with his family and he's been
going every year he's one of those guys
that goes chris johnson yeah and he's he
was telling me the price breakdown of
those things and it's like
a day in the park with your family's
like ten thousand if you want to do that
it's like insane so he doesn't do it he
just waited no no no no no i wouldn't do
it either like i don't know i don't know
just wait on the line yeah well by the
way when's the last time you were there
because i don't go but he told me they
revolutionized the system right now did
he go to the one in orlando one in
california he uh
cali that's where i'm going but i think
we're going yeah i i i they haven't had
at the brian improv yeah check them out
august 17th to the 20th love it they
have an app now so you can do that where
like you could pick where you want to go
and you get there you show them your app
and you walk on so like i think line
waiting is is reduced no no but i heard
that what the way they do it in disney
is is you get a speed pass let's say you
get a speed pass for space mountain
right your speed pass for space mountain
is from the hours of like 11 a.m to 1
p.m let's say you go on the ride at 11
15. you're off at 11 30. you cannot use
the speed pass again until after 1 pm
on another ride yeah you cannot use you
know what's the point of the speed only
speed pass one ride at a time
so you got to go on one ride every two
hours so they ration it yes so you're so
in that two hours that you're waiting
you should wait online for another ride
and then get on that ride and then you
time it where you get off and can go
directly i understand you're gonna after
you get your speedpass ride you go wait
on another ride to kill the time before
you have to go back to the exactly so
you're still waiting on every other ride
which is ridiculous but when you show up
for the speed pass in that window
doesn't so many other people have the
same window so are you waiting online
anyway for you between 11 and 1
i don't i don't know how they do it walt
disney's he does it in a way because
he's frozen he does
he's still pulling the strings just his
head it's just like
well is disney
disney there's an evilness to disney
yeah there's an inherent evilness to
this because why you just it's too it's
you can't be that much of a conglomerate
and not and not have
number one they own 90 of the porn in
the world that's a dirty little secret
they own pornhub do subsidiary companies
that's not true does disney own all
disney owns porn through subsidies
you're kidding me
disney acquires pornhub for new disney
after yep did
disney aft acquires porn up for new
disney at the dark
no they're not this is real
so
it's going to be
come on the avocado
disney's reputation we know that they
don't even f with any of that stuff
you're telling me they're going to do
dis it's going to be called disney at
the darkness report
can't be that can't be
they they acquired pornhub
so how could they do that it would
destroy
their entire reputation since their
inception but disney literally when you
go there first of all everything i
didn't realize and i i do support disney
everything is yes
everything
[Music]
everything is so overpriced yeah
the food is is is awful like not taste
always like they have no healthy options
here's what i believe if you didn't go
as a kid
and you don't have a nostalgia for it i
i don't understand the appeal i really
think that disney is god it's gotta be
overrated disney it's a theme park
disney is for adults
when you go to disney with children it
is so old that's why it's so sexy
it overwhelms the child it
overstimulates everyone all you see in
disney is people fighting with their
children really it is the most
so you're saying this for adults meaning
like go as an adult without kids yes or
go when your kids are older okay i'm not
i'm you know not even i'm not heeding my
own advice right so disney i am going to
disney and i will be there and i will
i'm telling you that morning i will take
a cbd edible i will take i will take
something i will calm down and what you
have to do is you have to go to disney
understand you may have a plan but if
your child may want to go on the same
ride five times that's what's going to
happen
that's what's going to happen because
they get too over stimulated they cannot
function you need to just
go with the flow what is why is mickey
mouse
and the castle
so great why
i think a child sees a mouse
and is not intimidated by it like oh
it's small like me it's got a squeaky
voice like me i think the castle is like
every kid just wants to think they're a
prince or a princess yeah um
i do know disney's is um
the
there's out crying out because the
disney
princesses i think are like non-gender
they're like gender-neutral now and it's
like a whole thing about disney going
woke that people are really pissed off
on the news yeah like shut up
dark secrets of disney you don't know
let's do this
yeah please take it
all right
by the way this is all
allegedly
walt disney was an fbi informant not
many people know that walt disney has a
special relationship with then fbi
director j edgar hoover um an informant
okay so so so walt disney was undercover
for the russians
disney was responsible for lemmings
committing mass suicide what
while shooting for a movie called white
wilderness update the name
disney cleverly used edits and angles to
deceive the viewer into thinking that
they were seeing what was natural
was a natural lemmings migration the
closing shot of the film shows a lake
filled with dead bodies of the lemmings
but in reality the lemmings did not jump
on their own
what's a lemming
isn't the lemming like a fish
who knows
there is no clear explanation regarding
abandoned parks some disney parks have
been abandoned without any clear
explanation with the most controversial
one being the river country disney
bringing the river country disney's
first water park
river country was closed down because of
dwindling footfall the reality is pretty
shocking what
oh
a brain eating amoeba was discovered in
the lake see that's what i'm talking
about you go in a lake and you can get a
brain eating amoeba yeah man with these
lakes
no i i don't like i don't like stagnant
you know lakes i mean a pond is even
worse but like isn't there stuff that
can go like up your pee hole oh yeah
well yeah dude because when i was in
when i was in uh i was in uh we filmed
an episode in new orleans and uh i was
in the bayou and i got i lost and they
put me in the swamps in the bayou and i
was so nervous
about alligators but about uh like
[ __ ] amoebas and [ __ ] and that i i
wore a condom through the whole thing
i swear to god wait did they put you in
the buyer where you could have actually
been attacked by an alligator yes they
did yes they did and and it was
the bayou was if you put your hand under
the water this is the water you put your
hand under the surface a centimeter you
couldn't see your hand anymore it was
pure thick brown like look i was in
chocolate milk and i got first they said
i was gonna go in there i said how do
you know there's no alligators and the
guy's answer to me was they don't come
over this way they're over there
and i said well what's to keep them from
coming over here he's like they just
don't come over here and i was like this
is insane that i had to get into this
and then how how submerged did you go
chest
i'm sitting in it and and by the way how
long i was in there for like like maybe
an hour maybe because what they what
they had me do is they put me in a
ghillie suit you know that's the ghillie
suit uh pull it up
you know pull up pull up a shane gilly
suit yeah just put my name and put uh
uh new orleans episode swamp bog monster
even
that's that's me
so
so wait
all right here we go
that's me so that's me so what they had
me do is emerge from the swamps when the
fan boat tours came by and like oh like
i was from the beasts from the swamps
so was that a real alligator that no so
they here's another thing i didn't know
existed
remote control alligators so they didn't
tell me that they had now that they did
that and then i looked up wait he just
hit me in the head okay pause this
there's some stories going into this so
then i'm in there and i'm just i'm
disgusted i'm disgusted and i have to be
hiding behind this rock and i'm i it
smells and there's mosquitoes and i feel
all the water and everything and so i
throw up i start throwing up but i'm not
allowed to move from behind this thing
for when the family's coming so and
there's no moving water so my vomit
after three or four vomits it's just oh
i'm sitting in a pool with my own vomit
before i went in there it was it was the
most awkward thing in the world but
before they dress me in that suit i said
what if a parasite goes in my peel and
so they had no answer for that and so i
the the sound guys have condoms because
they wrap the um lav mics in condoms a
lot of times if there's going to be like
near water or whatever and so i just
took a condom i put it on and that whole
entire bit i'm wearing a condom with a
soft penis pretty much yeah
like i couldn't maintain an erection for
like an hour for no reason
really hard i've done it but it's hard
and then
it's not over
yeah and then so that's a remote control
alligator and they they i didn't know
that that was they had that and i
literally had a did you see me run i
thought an alligator was coming at me
and when i ran to the boat joe thought
that i was wearing a helmet and he took
that oar and he slapped me in the head
with it and there was nothing but my
soft cranium underneath and he hit me
and my literally my eyes went to
blackout i almost went to blackout
and i almost fell back and underneath
the water
like oh my god i'm so sorry dude i was
like ah i was like that [ __ ] hurt he
goes i thought you were in hell and i go
no he goes oh my god i'm so sorry
jeez
so you're genuinely for real terrified
here terrified bro terrified is your
thought in alligators gonna come out of
nowhere and kill me i
how can you you can't see one inch under
the water who's telling me an alligator
is not coming is the bayou anywhere near
the city of new orleans do you have to
like drive to the jungle we drove it i'm
sure i can't remember but i'm sure it
was like
yeah because i had to listen to them and
they would give them the tour and the
tour guide goes the bog monster likes
when you ask him to dance so i had to
like do everything it was just me
they didn't tell me they didn't tell me
that that
guy that's my buddy jay miller
uh he's a he's a he's a writer on the
show a producer on the show comic
he was hiding the in a latex skin tight
he was hiding in those bushes behind me
for the one hour
and he he wasn't supposed to come out
till the end and the tour guide was like
uh this is the mating season so
sometimes another one will come out to
mate and he ran out of those bushes and
i didn't know that that was him either
he had on a full latex so i couldn't
tell it was even what it was and they
scared the [ __ ] out of me that way it
was one it was one of the worst ones you
leave there you're showering like what
10 times
like yes yes so
so they had
there was no shower immediately so they
had hoses
and they had a towels buckets with soap
and hoses and they had
like big things of antibacterial were
you so happy when they got yelled cut
it's over yeah i i remember thinking
like i can and also it was like a
hundred degrees of course so and i was
that suit was so hot dude like i i
that's why i probably almost fainted so
easily too when he hit me because like i
was not one of the most like regrettable
thing were you like ever at point like
what am i what am i doing yeah in that
one i was like what am i doing like i
was i mean it's look at it
i mean it's just like did you go to the
doctor after
i didn't couldn't you i mean i wore the
concept of new orleans
is that when you lost your voice didn't
you lose your voice in new orleans is
was it after you were the boss oh no no
that was no that was on the cruise i'm
going to new orleans for the first time
in november to mark norman's wedding
i'll be there oh good we'll go together
i i've never been to new orleans i'm
going there for the first time are you
going i i have i have shows the next
night though so i'm going in no
so i'm flying into new orleans for his
wedding and flying out the next day so i
have his wedding is a thursday on
purpose thursday yeah yeah yeah so i've
never been to new orleans i'm go never
once in my life i'm going in november
and then i'm going again in january for
a show what are you doing the show uh i
think the joy the joy theater yeah yeah
i've done it um
i will tell you what hotel my joy
experience um
these are not great hotels down there
anywhere in new orleans they're not
great they're all pretty old and
weathered you could
i mean there's a i think there's a w now
there's a ritz i think but like
they're
they're they're i would just i don't
know like i'm trying to think of like
ones that are not like
think about that every
who goes there they party they trash the
[ __ ]
it's jazz fest after mardi gras to this
set to that right so the hotel rooms are
all small it's super hot the air is like
yeah it's not it's not a great it'll be
hot november and january no it'll be
nice there maybe it'll be mild then i i
would assume yeah i was there and i've
been there so many times so when you did
bog monster that was like the summer
yeah it was bad yeah no it was bad but
that was a hell of a trip there that
week yeah yeah everyone is a method man
he was there filming a movie we hung out
like all week it was fun
i saw him on the street right anyway
about that one uh
i forgot now it is what it is
oh the joy i was coming off the cruise
when i did the joy i've done this
there's a sanger theater i was coming
off the cruise and so the the theater
was filled with fans from the cruise
and so it was a decent like it was fun
but for the most part my experience in
new orleans
it's playing there like five six times
is it's like it's it's one of my least
favorite places but there's nothing
against them but
people are drunk
and it's a hundred degrees and it's just
it's it never makes for like a really
really great show so far have you been
in new orleans ever pimp no i want to go
i've never i feel like you look like a
guy who's from new orleans you look like
john laraquette with the beard wow a
little bit right there what did you pull
that out of
uh i don't know you pull it away you
pull that out this hat dude this hat
makes me different
yeah
i've actually warmed up to the hat on
your head really yeah i mean now that
you just turned yeah this way and i saw
it from a different angle it reignited
how ridiculous it is but from this angle
i started to get used to it it's not bad
no i would die if i saw you out in that
like if i came out i was like what's up
man yeah like dad seriously if something
looks wrong
yeah something looks wrong about it yeah
it's a stupid it's it's a bad i want to
i almost want you to order another hat
or we can order another hat with a hey
babe card and see if it fits the same
like is it the designer did you get a
bad hat i i think it's a design because
i've it's not the first time i've i've
had a hat like that it's the third time
and and it's just like i don't know what
it is it's his style and look the guys
that what's it called present moment
shout out the reason i ordered that the
reason i ordered the hat is because i
thought it looked awesome i like the
frog on it i like that it's this present
moment i like what it says in the back
here
radiating unconditional love i thought
it was cool but i gotta be honest if
you're watching guys and we know that
you are yeah we know that you are it's
just it's you got to have a you got to
have some kind of disclaimer on the jpeg
on the website saying that this is two
inches in depth
because it's not fair to a guy like me
that has a regular hat like that if 50
of the proceeds went to the special
olympics we'd understand
yeah so shout out to you guys and you
seem like a great company but can i have
my money back because i can't get in
touch with anybody over there give us
some money or instagram yeah so you can
see it's just send me my money and chris
whatever happened with you and riffraff
with me and richard oh my god that's
right
so riff raff i i i i just met him once i
just met him once and he
told me because he had a tattoo that
said yo mtv on his neck and i was like
when did you get that tattoo he was like
a couple of weeks ago it was the first
time i was ever on mtv i was like you
just got mtv logo tattooed on your neck
he was like
and i was like all right
and then and then i i think he did guy
code or we did something i remember us
doing something together but i remember
that yo mtv um raps tattoo or the yo mtv
tattoo on his neck was just the thing i
remember oh and i remember him wearing
like neon green like pantsuit
and he's very tall yeah he he he must be
exhausting him to get up every day and
just go to the bank
like he has to do all those zigzags and
put everything on and i really wanted
him to get into the wwe but they
wouldn't let him in oh really why not he
made a run i don't know really i don't
remember that you know just what if like
you know when you're him you can't just
you can't have one off moment where you
like are just in regular clothes no in a
regular style right i think his actual
real name is if you had to guess
ziggy
yeah yeah
i don't know riff raff
um i bet you it's something southern
dupont we should play a game like is
this a wrap like we should play a game
we should play a game
like with with artists like you know put
up their name and say is this
riff raff or one of nick cannon's kids
can you look up reverend's name you got
to see this name hold on it's going to
pop up
of course we could have never guessed it
his name is horst horst christian simcoe
his name is horst simco
what kind of name is horst it's one
where you say
riffraff is better than this yes
yes
what i've never in my ever heard of the
name of the first name horst old high
german origin meaning man from the
forest
horst is also a translation of english
arie the nest of an eagle
all right poor simcoe is horse the
common name
three thousand eight hundred and thirty
first because i bet you half the amish
are name horst
is riffraff amish
it's the 3830
most common name in the united states i
mean how many nails last names are there
god
um but that's not horse is not his last
name it's no his last name is simcoe
right
what's your surname
all right
simcoe
jody high roller mtv riffraff dale
tantoni brendan halen
okay wait go scroll up
he was a member of the group with andy
three loco andy milac there and i see oh
i'm thinking of something else because
andy and dirt and and nancy and with
mickey mickey uh avalon and riffraff
were in that oh okay so that was that
was three locations two different groups
is he is he like on the radio like is he
is he a thing
he's big uh like will he can riff-raff
sell out madison square garden pimp
no
what can riffraff sell out
can i sell more tickets from riffraff
no allegedly
allegedly
i don't know i think he's just hanging
in there no comment i'm sure it's fine i
like riff raff or do we not like
riffraff i have no idea i don't know
actually i mean different seems like a
character i don't know anything about
him once i like this tattoo yeah i
wonder what would he like to hang out
with him oh let's get him on the pot
let's get him on the pod roof raff if
you're listening and we know that you
are
i don't know
the fact that takashi 69 still isn't
dead yet means like it's not none of it
was real what happened to him he's not
around anymore don't say that
you don't hear it you don't hear from
him
i don't know anything about it anymore i
don't know
i thought he was no but i don't even
think he got jack but i don't even hear
him doing music like he used to release
like a video every month does he do
music nah i don't know what's really
happening it seems like he might be
going broke i don't know
i have no idea
well listen man the proceeds of this
episode let's go start a gofundme for
takashi 6 9. and if he's in financial
trouble we're here to help man i found a
bananas and if you don't like that
take it out with bloom
don't be a cafe don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey